>> Bret: WELCOME BACK TO
"SPECIAL REPORT."
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE.
BOMBARDMENT KYIV OUT HERE.
AND KYIV SEEING THAT AS WELL.
MEANTIME RUSSIAN FORCES ARE
MOVING DOWN FROM THE NORTH AND
EAST TRYING THAT ENCIRCLEMENT
DOUBLING DOWN AS YOU HEARD FROM
THE CIA DIRECTOR IT HASN'T
HAPPENED YET.
THE BIGGEST STORY OF THE DAY
WILL BE WHAT POLAND HAS
ANNOUNCED THEY WANT TO MOVE
MAKING 29s TO THE RAMSTEIN OF
GERMANY AND POSSIBLY THEN MOVE
THOSE PLANES, JETS TO KYIV.
THE U.S. HASN'T FIGURED OUT
EXACTLY HOW THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN FOR IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
MEANTIME IN THE WESTERN PART OF
THE COUNTRY IN LVIV RIGHT HERE,
LEADERS ARE STRUGGLING WITH TENS
OF THOUSANDS O